gout is an arthritic disease of your
joints caused by too much uric acid in
your body normally your liver processes
various substances in your body
including purines which are components
of genetic material found both inside
your cells and in some foods you eat
when your liver breaks down purines a
waste product called uric acid is
produced your body disposes of this
waste through your kidneys which remove
it from your blood
when your liver produces too much uric
acid
or your kidneys do not remove enough of
it from your body
excess uric acid accumulates in your
blood resulting in a condition called
hyperglycemia
caffeinated beverages affect the waste
removal function of your kidneys by
increasing your urine output which
eliminates too much water from your body
a condition called dehydration
dehydration can result in a higher
concentration of uric acid in your
body's fluids when the concentration of
uric acid becomes too high from any of
these sources it can no longer stay
dissolved
the excess uric acid begins to form
needle-like crystals inside your joints
most commonly in your big toe formation
of uric acid crystals leads to an
inflammatory response
white blood cells from your immune
system attack the uric acid crystals
resulting in joint pain and inflammation
this is called an acute gout attack if
left untreated elevated uric acid levels
may result in lumpy deposits of uric
acid around your joint called at ofus
causing additional joint pain and
disfigurement
treatment for acute gout attacks
includes colchicine to prevent or reduce
joint inflammation non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs to reduce pain
and inflammation including aspirin
ibuprofen such as advil motrin and
nuprin naproxen such as a leave and
Naprosyn and steroid drugs such as
prednisone
treatment for chronic gout includes
drugs that promote uric acid excretion
and drugs that inhibit uric acid
production by your body
lifestyle changes to prevent recurrent
or chronic gout include reducing red
meat and shellfish in your diet limiting
the consumption of alcohol which is high
in purines limiting caffeinated
beverages exercising regularly and
drinking plenty of water